خلود ابو بكر اسمهن سرعان محتل مواقع
البحث واكتسح مواقع تواصل في السودان
مقطع فيديو للممثله السودانيه من مسلسل
زوجان ولكن والذي تقوم ببطولته
ظهر فيه عن طريق الخطا اجزاء من جسدها في
احد اللقطات المشهد اثاره هجوما ضد
الممثله خلود
ابو التواصل الاجتماعي في السودان اللقطه
حيث اتهم بعضهم ممثله بالاساء للمراه
السودانيه وبعد الضجه الكبيره التي اثارها
المشهد اقدمه الممثله السودانيه خلود ابو
بكر على الاعتذار عما بدر منها وطلبت من
الجميع مسامحتها ومسح مقطع الفيديو الذي
انتشر بكثافه حيث دخلت في نوبه بكاء
وحابهدي
بالطريقه دي
وعكس الناس والله سيئه جدا عني حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل
انا ما عندي حزب الله سبحانه وتعالى
الحسنى لانه انا بمثل في مسلسل اسمه زوجان
ولكن للاسف اذا اخذت لقطه من المسلسل
ودعاء تم التعامل معها بطريقه غلط
وانتشرت واخذت لواجب بصول هايله جدا
حصل بعض التنمر وبعد الاساعات لكن الحمد
لله على كل حال يعني لحد الان نحن ما
عارفين العمل او ليه عمل كده لكن انا ما
بقدر اقول غير انه هو شخص غلط طيب خلود
خليني بس انا هيك يعني افهم منك
اليس هذا اعتراف ضمن منك بانه في خطا ما
وانك كانه عم بتجاري هذا الموجه وموجه
الانتقادات اللي عمالها تطالبلك
صلاح حسن
انه انا اسلتي زي اي اس لمحافظه
لايف عشان اوضح سبب الحاجه اللي حصلت
معاكي انه ما غلطتي وانا ما كنت على دلايه
بها وانه انا ما طلعت على المشهد قبل
العرض
وطلبته من الناس اللي بتحبني انه تخفف
شويه الهدوم لانه انا عندي اسره
من الموضوع ده
فالناس بدات في اللايف يعني تضغط عليه
فانه
بعديها بفتله بعد التضامن الحسن من كثير
من الناس انا بحب اشكلهم ااه قمت عملت
المقطع بتاع الفيديو ده شكلت الناس اللي
وقفت جنبيه وقلت للشخص العمل كده انه انا
بفوت امليل الله سبحانه وتعالى
فما كان يعني ما كانت الحاجه دي مقصود
منها انه انا اختلف بخطا او كده لا بس انا
شكلت الناس واعتزلتها اذا بدل حاجه طيب
اين كان القائمون عن العمل
والله همم
لكن معمول يعني في وقتيها
في بعض الاشعه البسيطه
بعد الاشياء البسيطه فالغيمون على العمل
يعني طلعوا وضحوا الحاجه دي انه هم
ملكت دي بالذات حتى الحاجه ركزوا عليها
الاداء بتاعي تعبان الثانيه
هو غلط وان شاء الله بتعالج اهم الحمد لله
وانا بعتذر بس المشهد كان غير مخصوص
واي زوج شاف المشهد هيكون شافوا انه مشهد
عادي لكن هو كان صمليط عمل زومبي مقابل
مشهد بسهوله غير اخلاق هي وزاد فيه وحاجات
كثير
[موسيقى]